let's take another question all right
this is from reddit entrepreneur
subreddit I've been spending some time
there
I think I'm my handle is just Jason
Calacanis it might be Jason Calacanis
what are some cliches that entrepreneur
phrases that make your eyes glaze over
that's a great question
there's a lot of bad advice out there
I'm trying to think of what is the worst
advice I've heard of late you know it's
a really good question you know all of
this advice is situational so let me
just take a different spin on this
because I can't think of a cliche off
the top of my head that I hate or that
make me a glaze over what I will tell
you is advice is situational and then
there are outliers and those outliers
are you know the exceptions that make
the rule so if you see some company
raise a ridiculous amount of money and
you're like well that doesn't make any
sense it could be a fluke it could be a
random piece of behavior and you know
it's one of those things that you have
to take all the advice you can get as a
founder and then you have to understand
that the best decisions the best
decisions you can make will come from
data and talking to customers now
creating value building a brand I know
the original poster brings up some of
those things you know building a brand
is a real thing you know apples brand
means something to people
instagrams mean sometimes people even
brand lists the unbranded brand one now
means something to people hustle I think
and disruption are two words that are
becoming maligned the reason Hustle is
becoming maligned it's because I think
people find Gary Vaynerchuk a little bit
abrasive in his approach he's candid
he's from New York he wants to see
people succeed and I think people on the
west coast are a little it's the East
Coast West Coast thing they're like
you don't know it doesn't have to be
crazy at work and it you can take it
easy you don't have to hustle a lot of
that advice about not hustling is a
reaction to mental health breakdowns
that people have had suicides burn out
and again it's situational to my point
earlier if you're in a competitive space
and it's lift versus uber versus sidecar
and you don't hustle you become sidecar
or if you hustle less you become lyft
now is lyft a failure at a twenty or
thirty billion dollar valuation versus
uber seventy eighty ninety one hundred
no it's not a failure it's a huge
success anybody can build a ten twenty
billion dollar business is built a huge
success but if they had hustled maybe
they would have beat Herber if they had
more hustle in them and so to be anti
hustle means you're saying you're okay
with not being first place the teams
that win in the NBA the Olympians
they're hustling and they're sacrificing
so people who achieve greatness
sacrifice they may sacrifice by not
seeing their family or kids as much as
people who do if an Olympian said I am
going to train for the next 60 days in
the mountains and I'm not gonna see my
kids for the next 60 days many people
would say ok your kids will appreciate
that you made that sacrifice they will
forgive you for taking those 60 days off
from the family to go train at some
elevation if you come back and you've
got a gold or silver medal and you
placed in the Olympics it's an
understandable sacrifice when it comes
to business people might be less I think
that's less meaningful I don't I think
if you had to sacrifice maybe not see
your family for some period of time
you're in a business trip you might be
setting the example that hard work is
virtuous and that hustling is worth it
now if you're hustling and you're
sitting in front of your computer every
day replying to email that is not
actually moving the needle for you well
maybe that you didn't need to sacrifice
and not see your family or not see your
friends under no circumstances should
you hustle to the point of which you
have a nervous breakdown and consider a
horrible decision like suicide and so I
think it's very easy to fall on either
side of the hustle debate but the truth
is it's situational and it's very
nuanced and I don't criticize people who
don't want to hustle because they want
to have an easy life and they want to
surf and they want to wake up naturally
and go to bed under the stars and not
check their phone for a month Mazel Tov
that's your choice go for it I'm big on
individual freedom and I'm big on people
having into a visual freedom at
different points in their life
I do not hustle in the insane way I used
to I used to be a seven-day-a-week
12 hour a day person but you know what
now I'm at the top of the hill and I
fought my way here and I could take it a
little bit easy yeah of course if I want
to take a vacation I can take it if I
want to come into work at 11 o'clock I
can do that and that's what I do I work
from home I don't do any meetings until
11:00 because I like to have that time
in the morning with my family I like to
have that time in the morning to write
and to think I've earned that but
previously I was getting in to work at
7:00 a.m. 8:00 a.m. every day and
staying till midnight and I I was very
one-dimensional in that way for a good
part of my career when I was coming up I
don't regret it may be rich and powerful
and so I think that there is this hustle
debate is really interesting most of the
time when I hear people say you don't
have to hustle and doesn't you don't
have to be crazy at work they're already
millionaires or deca millionaires were
sent to millionaires and they're looking
backwards saying oh I could have done
this without but you know if Elan must
takes the pedal off of Tesla well it
could die so he's got no choice but to
hustle and if you have Zuckerberg as a
competitor in your snapchat and you take
your foot off the pedal you're gonna get
run over which by the way is what
happened to snapchat they got run over
and they still exist it's a five billion
dollar business but you know Zuckerberg
definitely out hustled them and so now
when it comes to disruption that's a
whole nother charged word what
disruption means is you're not going to
accept the status quo and you're willing
to take risks and you're willing to
maybe bend the rules disruption has a
negative tone occasion when the bending
of the rules breaks something in society
so if you want to bend the rules about
scooters and somebody takes their
scooter into the middle of street and
kills themself yeah you're gonna look
like a douche and if you you know
allowed the scooter to go too fast
because you wanted people to get to the
destination too fast you can come up
with all the different examples out
there if you're gonna bend
rulz you're gonna reinterpret the rules
like a scooter company might or Airbnb
might you better make sure people are
not getting hurt in the process too
badly or that the risk is not too high
if you're taking a ton of risk well that
can be dumb and so you better make sure
that bending the rules is not dangerous
and is not in the your interest above
the consumers and societies so Facebook
bent the rules a whole bunch they
weren't checking who was buying ads and
the Russians bought ads in rubles to try
to create racial tension in our country
to subvert the african-american vote
versus you know in favor of Trump and
against Hillary this kind of dark stuff
that's the kind of disruption Society
does not like or wholesale giving over
your information to advertisers and
partners so you can make more money
that's the kind of disruption that
society doesn't like disrupting saying
hey you can rent out your extra bedroom
in Paris and Tokyo and make a little bit
of extra money if you lost your job or
provide a $50 a night option for people
can't afford to go to Paris and you
opened up Paris and Tokyo to a whole
nother group of people to visit
mazelTov high five great that's what
kind of bending of rules we need we need
some bending of rules if it's the
bending of the rule of you you know you
eliminate dealerships from the car
buying process like Tesla's done and
they sell direct that's great nobody
wants to deal with some dealership
nonsense middlemen who ruins the process
we all wanted to buy direct on a website
and get it so understand if you want to
if we're talking about hustle and
disruption which are charged words there
are situationally times when you want to
hustle and you want to disrupt but you
have to do it in a sophisticated fashion
you don't want to hustle for no reason
and you certainly don't want to disrupt
and have people get hurt in the process
great question
[Music]